so
[Music]
so the timing is part of the technique
this is not part of the technique do you
see this
right yes
[Music]
you hi
okay
so where is that pressure coming from
the arms inside who's
yours
it's
activated
not here in your shoulder hi
stay there
no
extension
here though
not in your shoulder hi
extension relax
with extension
you want to relax and drop it relax it
in space
with extension
oh you really stayed high when you felt
yourself falling
please
just hurting yourself
very lost
hi
we're over here we're over here
way
lock your body
lock your body we're going this way
that's the bracing
so when it goes fast it goes right into
that shoulder
you can touch it
but reconcile the mat hi
we go this way
that pause is not
[Music]
keep going
you keep dragging your patella right
there
hey
how much do you wait for
195.
indeed 195
fell on my lower leg
right
what's the state of my ankle
it's up
tell me if you see it or here
okay
as i move in a way
that is in alignment
with nature
but my patella is not meant to be dry
because it
can i use moves
instead of lines
lines i'm going to have to go far but
you're going to go around
now i'm going to go around my other knee
and that's it
don't escape
you can top
around this knee and you around me
around this knee
be around you don't escape pipe you can
tap
i won't tell you a third time
my feet
stand you can top
okay
don't push them
don't want to push it then you're going
to do lines
then you're going to drag your patella
then you're going to get injured
then you can't train
keep going
the trolls
[Music]
hey
well i can't show you this because your
body you won't do it
you have to watch
you can't do it
you're going to be too mushy all right
when you get afraid you get much
okay see if the watch
you can feel how much
strength you're having to use okay you
feel that right yeah there's one time
there was a failure too right this is
not enough strength
um
yin must proceed young
okay
tencon and edemi are intimately
related okay
tangon doesn't mean when you do that one
foot maneuver where you make a circle
around yourself that's not what it means
that's eight type of tencon
to make that point we have another one
called we call it a shield tank in our
millions right this is a different tempo
there's lots of different templates
so
yes he's coming in and yes i have to
send him into the
front
inward position true
okay
but i could do that here
and that would not be equal
it would do
front inward position but not equal okay
so ichio is going to have
this kind of shape to it
you can think of it as
somebody's coming in
yield and flank
yield and flank okay
if you just think of it as that it
it works on
almost any form of aggression yield in
flank yield then flying
okay yield and fine all the time
even if you had multiple forces
you had standing armies
and you yield to pull them into the
ambush and a flanking
detail would kill them off
it's been used throughout history okay
you could even use it in business yield
and flank
yield and flag hey you're getting what
you're not no you're not
okay
so
let me attach the yield and flank
strategy to the front inward
position mechanics
okay
so instead of over here
and doing this
i'll do it in a way
that they feed each other
see
okay
what exactly does that mean well here i
will yield the flank
right but what can you tell
what can you feel that's freaking heavy
do you see that
so it it's going to help me determine
how far do you yield
got it how far do you heal
well
your yield according to your iq and coq
skills your internal skills will dictate
what you have to do externally
okay
what you want to do
is to reconcile
that resistance point
you can do it all let's say i have no
internal skills
i'll take it
but you'll just feel when that when that
pressure goes off okay
do you feel it decreasing you see can
you see it's decreasing as i move this
way go back over here
oh that's heavy
and i'm going to move out
[Music]
and now this is light this is getting
lighter
if i have internal skills that
resistance point is reconciled
internally his energy goes through me so
even though he's on top of me it's not
doing what you think it's going to do
okay he's just going to pass through me
hit the ground and it adds to
the projection okay so
very quick
[Music]
see
that would be the minimum like i gotta
reconcile that energy and i can
reconcile it according to my internal
skills or laughter
what is the maximum
it would be when i take him out of the
front inward position
he's never going to go right into it
okay
and the angle that you're going to take
when you yield them flanking ikkyo
is
this way
this way but it's dynamic
so it might start that way
it goes right into the other one
what it won't do is this
okay
so he's committed you see it right there
this way
yield
so watch how my knee goes
[Music]
of course if y'all you can really push
push push you can stand up
there's a lot a lot of energy i have uh
internal skills and it'll work
the same way
squishy
but we want to do this tactic
yield and flank
guild and flight
what's happening is i do the rest i
don't stop anymore but you can see that
i move into the yield and flight
position
okay so first one
all righty here we go
i can tell where that hid space is going
to be on the grip
there there it is
okay
let's just do the opening
take away
as much resistance
as you need externally or reconcile that
contention point internally if you have
that skill
[Music]
okay so you're reconciling it
but biomechanically
in a biomechanically unsound way okay
you are bending your arms moving into
the heavy space
heavy so you go like this
see where that is see where it came off
it's heavy right here and you feel it
heavy so you go like that
instead of doing this stay
move your body
there
you see okay so at the beginning not
here like this
leave your
dirty
elbow and move into that
okay
we're in front of our center
hey
so this part here
is not a
skeletal
manipulation
you're not good
okay
see i'm i'm gonna turn your wrist make
your elbow come up and then your elbow
is pulling you off
but see what your center feels like okay
see how it's just there see how it's
nothing nothing right nothing then about
here i get it you see that
you get that do it again stay conscious
um
yep
no i didn't you don't feel it in your
center did you have to move let's see
that so just stay where you are and
you'll feel when it starts to fit there
you see for example go back and sit down
see how it resisted you see that so
before when you were doing this last rep
you just moved over with your elbow you
see that
okay just stay there until you feel it
manipulate yourself can you sit down
oh a little bit more or can you sit back
down and say something there you go
it wasn't kind of there right now it
starts to take
okay
the other one
you can just feel your center okay
and try to leave it still in place try
to stay safe
you see it's already moving
and then the other one
don't just stay seated
all right
[Music]
okay
so if i go in front of you even if i'm
healing
you just turn your elbow
because of a cultural thing
can you sit there
and on the other one
you feel that okay
it's in your body you see
right
so first one
stay seated
i'm in front of you all this is up here
you see
and really
open your grip
and you can see
nothing to it
okay
open your grip and you could see
it was in your center
okay
so
out yield
feel their center
take their center into the condition
don't take their line of gravity
outside their base of support
do you see that okay
their line of gravity will fall outside
of their basic support by what you're
incidentally doing with your pattern the
fielded flank but this is the center of
that
[Music]
and
okay
do you see that little forward there
do it exactly the same
[Music]
that
one
okay think about it i'm going forward
because
uh
i want to be spreading out
thank you first let me do the
the errors that you can
is some fetish about
this ending position
do you get it
i mean if you dig deeper it was pretty
comfortable for you wasn't it right can
you see it's the ending position for you
a comfortable luke
they'll understand how that would be
part of the form
your comfortability
is not my problem
it's your problem
hey do you get it okay
so this is going to be the same thing
uh when i was telling virginia not to
escape
do you remember
why was she escaping it was
uncomfortable it's very uncomfortable
okay
but your tool that you have
is what
keeping my center connected with the
outfit what was the tool i told virginia
tap okay so let's figure out why you why
you might want to tap hey okay
so i'm going to get on the inside of
here grip
you see hey what do you feel is it
loosening or tightening
let's do the other one
hi
okay
so
boom i'm going to go around this inner
knee
and get on the inside of your arm
the inside
and the path for it is in a circle
watch it go off i start going straight
you see that
i'm going to tighten this inside the
surface i'm going around this cell now
let's say i do care about you like
you're not taking care of yourself okay
his eyes letting her
slide out a little bit
got it
so i might want to
just let it up do you see
and i end up here look at my knee
instead of here
to me this is better i let you out of
the technique so i don't keep my knee
there do you get it but i don't put my
knee there and never put you in the
technique do you understand that
difference okay
around me
and it's gonna go around this knee
then i'm gonna let you out
you see that all right
if you want to play that game
otherwise they can tie
okay is that not the rule
i got no more space to reconcile
with yin energy your young energy
tap you control it
and then the young energy is off
okay
thank you let's play with this yield and
flag so we'll just start with some
abstract uh vectors
he's gonna push you can have your other
hand
okay so i'm gonna yield here yield here
i have this pop here and get that okay
and this hand is here but i'm not
knocking it off
there's the yield
side
okay
so the yield
you
okay
[Music]
hold the other hand down we're working
on multiplying
push the other hand up
[Music]
right and here is you i have reconciled
that energy
okay right
pretty light yes okay
but
if you take a new vector just stand up
and come over here
i really appreciate
i'm not following that
okay
it's not an external field
from a gui center
if you
i reconcile
okay
and you come over here
and you push just change it you can
change
[Music]
is
so when i heal it's not out of weakness
so anywhere in the technique
right let's say
you feel the yield there okay so i got
there and the same thing
you push
it's not weak
it's ground you see yes
and i yield
okay
don't confuse that's the problem when
everything is external with no internal
it's weak
okay it might be a training step
but it's not practical and it's not the
heart okay get your ground vector
yield
yielding is not
think of yielding as tactical
repositioning
it's not retreating
externally
i can stay here and let that energy pass
through me so he's pushed he's pushing
on but
you just let it pass through and bounce
it off the ground okay by releasing all
right
so
same thing here
he's driving and you don't realize that
he's pounding he's making you feel
threatened
and you're pushing into him
and as a result
you're generating friction between the
two surfaces you see
so
even though
you're kind of moving
as you get scared or you start to desire
the throw
you're pushing in but he's he can drive
let's just exaggerate his drive you see
and uh i'll just start releasing
without any of the deviation do you see
that and so
first so you can see it on this side
okay
so again subconsciously there's all this
stuff and you're just creating more
friction but if you if you release you
just release release release
you get slippery because you don't
because relative to what i just
demonstrated you're not pressing the two
surfaces together okay so if we're doing
the movement it doesn't take a big thing
got released it's done
got it so maybe it's a guy uh coming in
to grab and punch
and you're in do you see because i don't
have all that time i just released right
away and i'm
i am responding but it looks more like i
initiated but i didn't okay
so as you go to release
remember the internal aspects and not
just the external aspect because
again that's not the art because it's
not practical
okay let's try to try the other way okay
so this time we're on the homologous
side right
because it's going to emphasize more of
the binding okay
so i i'm going to release release
release
and my external is going to be a turn
and if need be i'll take this step
but
i'm releasing releasing releasing this
is enough
okay
just that slightly okay
so i'll do the slight turn
[Music]
boom
push
start bringing our hands back in
and up
[Music]
okay let's get so let's let's understand
the earlier point i may say he when we
do our
keyhole he has spinal displacement so if
i'm not grounding when he comes in he's
attacking my center
he's attacking my center
and that was the energy that i'm
reconciling here sending to the ground
and then refusing to project him
and earlier we described
what was too minimal
a yield in flank
because this was that energy of the
spinal displacement
was still too great to send in another
direction
and i told you the maximum though
was when we start taking them out of the
front inward kazushi and we start going
this way
you see that
usually people that do that version is
now they set up
the front inward kazushi from the guy
who went down okay they don't let go
this time
he's here
and he gets up and then you go with him
you see
um
i don't like the what-if techniques
to me kihon is to not do what-ifs it's
fine to do what ifs but they're not kill
on to me
okay you're
playing with a keyboard
got it
um
well
i would say that that would have you
fall out of e kill
okay and then you started again
okay
same thing here
i go like this i'm going to reconcile
this with my yield you see and then my
flank
but i'm over here
i've fallen out of the technique
okay
instead as he's going i'm still
forward
it's very miserable he's driving on me
his other hand is up right
and i'm in
you see that i'm not gonna go he's stuck
he's stuck because i'm pushing on it
pushing on look how far i have to turn
to get that thing to come off
or how much strength
i have to use
to get it off
it's just a pass that's enough
a pass
don't take yourself out of the id me
okay let's try so uh
same thing yield and flank will not move
from these abstract vectors and he's got
like a jab cross combination
and it'll be the same thing boom boom i
just gotta get to the outside yeah
oh
it is
okay
let's try